[Música]
en Ecuador arranca el proceso electoral
al decretar la muerte Cruzada para
esquivar un juicio político el
presidente Guillermo lasso disolvió El
parlamento y adelantó los comicios
residenciales y legislativos
alerta en Colombia ante el aumento de la
violencia contra los líderes sociales
abril de 2023 se ha convertido en el mes
más mortífero en el último año para los
defensores de los Derechos Humanos en el
país con 22 homicidios registrados
en Argentina el observatorio de la deuda
social indica que seis de cada diez
menores viven bajo el umbral de la
pobreza el costo de la vida en el país
continúa en aumento con una inflación
interanual que supera el 100%
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
mas deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles Y empezamos en Ecuador
donde el Consejo Nacional electoral ya
dio por iniciado el proceso electoral y
prevé anunciar la fecha de los comicios
el próximo miércoles 24 de mayo unas
elecciones anticipadas después de que el
pasado miércoles el presidente Guillermo
lasso disolviera la asamblea nacional
con el mecanismo de muerte Cruzada para
evitar un juicio político en su contra
desde quito Gustavo Ortega nos amplía
si Efectivamente es que con la
declaratoria del proceso electoral por
parte del Consejo Nacional electoral ya
comienza a correr lo que son las fechas
tentativas para realizar estas
elecciones anticipadas de presidente y
del órgano parlamentario Y en este
sentido una de las características era
Modificar el calendario electoral para
cumplir tal y como dice la Constitución
con el proceso de elecciones en 90 días
y en este sentido ya se conoce un
calendario tentativo es que el
vicepresidente del Consejo Nacional
electoral Enrique Pita ya ofrecido
información que sería ratificada el
próximo 24 de mayo en este sentido la
información que se conoce hasta este
momento es que el 24 de mayo sería
confirmada ya la convocatoria a
elecciones del 25 al 30 de mayo las
organizaciones políticas deben realizar
sus procesos de democracia interna para
elegir así a quienes serán los
postulantes para
candidatearse por los distintos cargos
de elección en popular y este mismo
sentido también del 25 al 30 estará
realizándose el registro de las alianzas
los partidos políticos deberán informar
con qué Alianza Irán y De igual forma
tenía el plato fuerte de este proceso
electoral el ocho de agosto la
inscripción de los candidatos y las
elecciones serían Entonces el el 20 de
agosto y de realizarse una segunda
vuelta el quince de octubre otro punto
destacar Es que la campaña política por
las primeras magistraturas solo se
desarrollará Durante los siete días un
proceso que regularmente me tiene
campañas electorales entre 30 y 40 días
en este país por el cual se prevé una
campaña electoral bastante intensa para
lograr así con los puestos de elección
popular y vamos a Colombia donde avanza
la búsqueda de los cuatro menores que
desaparecieron tras un accidente de
avioneta el pasado 1 de Mayo en la
amazonía en el siniestro murieron tres
adultos incluido el piloto nuestro
enviado especial al terreno Luis Muñoz
habló con la abuela de los niños
desaparecidos
estamos acompañando a María Fátima
Valencia Ella es la abuela de los niños
que sufrieron un accidente el primero de
mayo en el que perdieron a su madre y
que actualmente está el país volcado en
su búsqueda Doña Fátima que es lo último
que han sabido de los niños
puesto un momento Buenos días mi nombre
es Mario Fátima Valencia
es tu momento pues los niños ellos lo
miran los huellas de que yo duerme o de
que yo mantiene Entonces estos momentos
Pues
necesitamos despertar un relevo Los
Paisanos porque todo esto lo situaciones
lo encontraron los paisanos de nosotros
Y ahora yo necesito meter otro rapidito
necesito urgente para que busque los
niños se siente ya agotado Hasta no ver
mis nietos no voy a estar contento no
voy a respirar
en todo el país está pendiente el mundo
entero
hay esperanza de encontrar los vivo es
usted cree que están vivos Sí yo creo
porque en otro tenemos una cultura de
verdad que creemos a mi Dios y la virgen
Guadalupe no tiene que acompañar cuando
llegue aquí nosotros la parte los lo que
somos la tía los tíos vamos a estar
contento pues ya Gracias mi Dios pues ya
mi hija se fue ya ella no va a sufrir ya
el que vamos a sufrir son nosotros y ese
recuerdo de mi hija que quedará mi nieto
entonces yo necesito este grande país el
doctor Petro también que no apoye con
los ejércitos porque es muy duro para mí
Muchas gracias María Fátima y Seguiremos
informando con nuevas novedades sobre el
rescate de los cuatro niños y
continuamos en Colombia donde el mes de
abril fue el más violento del último año
para los líderes sociales esto según el
Instituto indepaz que confirma 22
asesinatos de Defensores de los Derechos
Humanos en ese periodo Daniela garzón
investigadora de la fundación pares paz
y Reconciliación nos habló de las causas
de estos niveles de violencia
sí Bueno yo creo que este año tenemos
varios factores el primero de ellos por
supuesto es que en Colombia es un año
electoral este año vamos a elegir
alcaldes gobernadores consejos y
asambleas Y por supuesto cuando hay un
periodo electoral y más con desde
carácter local es posible que aumente la
violencia nosotros veníamos de un
periodo de tensa calma en 2019 y pues
como sea deteriorado la paz en el país
en los últimos años pues creemos que
esto tiene que ver precisamente con el
aumento de esta violencia por supuesto
dentro de los liderazgos sociales hay
muchos comunitarios pero también hay
otros por ejemplo de personas que están
haciendo campaña el último
Lamentablemente fue el asesinato ayer en
catatumbo de una persona que estaba
pensando en postularse para esas
elecciones de octubre entonces creo que
eso es uno de los factores el otro sin
duda ha sido una falta de coordinación
con los grupos armados y de poder
establecer que los teses al fuego no
solo tengan que ver con las acciones
contra la fuerza pública sino
especialmente que presenten un alivio
humanitario para las personas que están
en las zonas de conflicto
y vamos a Argentina donde un nuevo
informe del observatorio de la deuda
social señaló que seis de cada diez
menores viven bajo el umbral de la
pobreza
estos últimos meses no han sido fáciles
para Jacqueline Mister Rigo y sus dos
hijas que han dependido de los comedores
sociales del colegio y de los trabajos
esporádicos para poder subsistir una
realidad compartida por muchos en
Argentina desde que llegué acá
las primeras dos semanas nunca tuve para
darle de comer esas dos semanas mí los
comedores me ayudaron un montón e
incluso con ropa todo aunque la familia
tiene problemas aún más graves tras
recibir una orden de desahucio temen que
los echen de su casa la próxima semana
mira tengo miedo mucho miedo de quedarme
en la calle literalmente de quedarme acá
esperar el desalojo y quedarme en la
calle una situación que puede parecer
insostenible pero por la que muchas
personas atraviesan en el país y que
afecta especialmente a los niños según
un informe del observatorio de la deuda
social Argentina seis de cada 10 menores
viven en condiciones de pobreza en el
país algo que ha aumentado los índices
de trabajo infantil y que todavía podría
emp con la alta inflación del país es
muy probable que esto empeoren en un
contexto de inflación porque la gran
mayor la mayor parte digamos de los
ingresos de estos hogares están
destinados a los consumos alimentarios
este último año la inflación ha sido un
problema en todo el mundo pero Argentina
ocupa el segundo lugar en la
clasificación del Banco Mundial solo en
abril el precio de los alimentos aumentó
un 10% algo que atenta contra el
bienestar de muchas familias y
especialmente de los más pequeños
y la NASA dio a conocer que Blue origin
de Jeff bezos construirá el módulo que
transportará los astronautas desde la
nave espacial hasta la superficie lunar
en el proyecto de regreso a la luna
Estados Unidos da un paso más en su
proyecto de regreso a la luna la NASA
dio a conocer la unión de un nuevo
contratista privado a su equipo de
trabajo la empresa escogida es propiedad
de uno de los hombres más ricos del
planeta Jeff bezos nosotros
anunciamos que Blue origin y sus socios
de lockhead Martin draper Boeing
astrobotic y Johnny borics construirán
un sistema de aterrizaje humano para
llevar a los astronautas de la NASA a la
superficie lunar el presupuesto asignado
al contrato ronda en los 3.400 millones
de dólares el módulo lunar de Blue
origin facilitará el alunizaje De los
astronautas su tarea consiste en
trasladarlos desde una nave en órbita
constante hasta el suelo lunar y
regresarlos al vehículo espacial
queremos establecer la permanencia en la
luna y queremos asegurarnos de tener
acceso constante a la luna con capacidad
para dos personas su diseño ayudará a
permanecer una semana en terreno lunar
se prevé que el módulo se utiliza en la
misión tripulada artemis 5 para 2029
con respecto a las misiones anteriores
el nuevo aparato contará entre otras
novedades con más espacio habitable Blue
origin se suma spacex la compañía de
otro magnate elon musk esta desarrolla
su sistema starship un nuevo prototipo
de cohete reutilizable con más capacidad
de carga y alcance de lo acostumbrado
hasta que las noticias
[Música]